Joel we often talk about the seniors
Championship as not as theoretical but I
have to say today you guys were fighting
a deeply theoretical battle
well it's it's an opening that I played
last year against Nick deferman and I
put a lot of time into it
um in in previous outings Max has played
in a completely unsound way uh in this
variation for black he did Once in a
game against federovich many years ago
and he did it in the Blitz game against
me in the park but I had no had no
illusions that he was going to play to
to play like that today so he he was uh
he was pretty well prepared but then we
got to a point where I made what I
thought was an obvious move and he said
that it was unusual which one was that
this one H3
I mean that's what my computer says to
do yeah I think that's the point before
I think F4 is the only idea for white to
and the thing is the position uh it's
all about timing you know because why it
is wants to open the position for the
bishop pair yes and you know black
voices idea of playing Knight D7 to E5
after after uh
it's a question of uh who got gets there
in time I thought he was not quite in
time but then didn't seem that I had
much anyway yes and he actually played
quite well were you worried at any point
that you might end up in a strategically
worse position for the similar fact that
you know you had no no because because I
saw concretely that that I was going to
dissolve that pawn yeah I mean if he had
time to put a knight in E5 and put a
Pawn on C5 yes I would be worried about
that position but you got the C5 in I
got it and I thought it would do a
little more and no probably I could put
after Rook FDA it's possible to play
better so somehow it requires some
subtlety and it does say that Queen D4
is the best move in the position it says
it's the best move really okay yeah
Queen to D4 F6 it felt like both of you
played quite a precise game I have to
say so it was it was uh correct to trade
off the minor pieces right correct I I
mean it seemed like it was very drawish
to me but I didn't see anything better
yeah Joel uh you don't play that much
but you whenever you come to this one it
feels like you come prepared how much
preparation do you do before this event
in general well this year I I think I I
put more time in it than usual because I
I made the decision that I was didn't
want to be working really hard every day
you know putting in two or three hours
and I've done that in the past and it's
just a physically debilitating so I kind
of think that my you know my work is
basically done for for all the games I'm
hoping already wow yeah so like really I
didn't uh today I was really just just
checking some lines but in hindsight I
you know I wish I had checked this a
little bit more you know like um like
Queen E7 was not a move that I had uh
the the my my computer was saying black
shirt by Bishop E6 in that position and
I just sort of followed the main line
which is very silly you always have to
put some Alternatives in there because
you never know what your opponent was
going to do so I was feeling very stupid
when he played Queen E7 that I didn't
have that worked out that I could have
but I probably couldn't have done any
better than I did no it was a very
correct game guys join the conversation
uh congratulations Joel uh for the
preparation I want to say because that's
the way I feel that when you come to the
event you can't spend three hours
preparing and then think that you're
gonna play a beautiful five-hour game
you're already
energy is is down so I like the fact
that you're doing all your preparing in
advance
yeah I mean that's it's the that way for
me the key is is really to have uh to
have enough energy to play the games and
um you know also I I tend not to sleep
that well so I'm tired to begin with so
I you know I need to conserve whatever
energy I can
well good luck in your campaign one more
question about the Hall of Fame is that
your first time playing a tournament
there because we used to play at the
settlers chess club or a Sub-Zero how do
you like the space there you know I've
been here many times and it seems every
year it's different you know I just sort
of you know got gotten adjusted to
playing the games uh on the corner like
last year and suddenly it's in in the
Hall of Fame and uh so that's uh just a
new a new layout again but
um whatever room they put us in it's
pretty pretty much the same it's it's
high quality conditions there's plenty
of space air conditioning seems to be
working fine and there's you know snacks
and Beverages and um
so it's it's all good
um today we we played in that sort of
little cubby hole in the corner which I
think is nice but they've told us that
we're going to rotate into the main room
as well so you know hopefully that will
be just as pleasant
perfect thank you well good luck in the
rest of the tournament I appreciate that
it doesn't hurt to have it absolutely
absolutely